things and I think accurate records of
this illegal transaction
this will never leak
[Music]
hey Bart so like what was your job in
the military were you the guy who like
inventored stuff when stuff fell off the
back of the truck
yeah kind of feels like a setup yeah do
you know like uh price points for things
did you also like have like
whoa this guy's a real expert he's
thinking he's thinking standard issue
tongue do you like for example remember
like can you just give us any random
things you remember like how much it
costs for like a tank or a grenade or a
truck or a rifle or whatever they're all
overpriced though oh really yeah I
remember uh so the school that I went to
it's called like Supply Administration
school and you kind of keep track in
like pretty much like you could do
inventory and order all the parts and
everything that like a unit would need
and then there's a software system I
forgot what it's called but uh at the
school I would just type in random
things so there's a thing called the
Excel no
I think I just type in random stuff I
think it's called that it's really
complex system Google this Google and
what is NSN number I think that's what
it is well you know bookshelf ISBN
number yeah and that tells you what that
book is so every a NATO stock number or
national okay it is it is a 13 digit
numeric code used by that okay be quiet
so you type it you you type it the NSN
number
and then I'll tell you the pricing of it
and I remember like at that time in like
2003. this show the whole setup they are
at the store at [ __ ] big five is like
500 bucks right so I'm like oh this
thing if we're buying in bulk I'm
guessing 200 300 because you get a deal
right yeah I type it in 500 bucks and
I'm like holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] military
is buying things at retail so everything
we're buying at retail like all the
Humvees even though you're getting
thousands of yeah you would think like
you would buy a thousand Humvees maybe
it'd be not 100 you get a fleet price
yeah but it's not they're all full price
sleeping bag full REI price whatever the
[ __ ] those prices are and I just
remember going dude this is how these
companies make hell of money I wonder if
the PD will do that with Crown
Victoria's too like when they buy Fleet
cop cars I wonder if like Ford charges
this the city like this probably I'm
sure they margin sucks so it may look
like they're they're spending that money
and maybe they are but they're margining
it in some some sort of way I could also
assume that in those transactions kind
of like like uh it's like um how much uh
how much you're gonna charge it for just
charge full price the city's paying for
it anyway you know what I mean when you
don't have an emotional connection to
the money like you earned it yourself
you're just like oh yeah just charge
full price we need more we need more
emotions in the military that's why
you know even like that like
like Club at like any foyer
if you don't use that budget next year
the
um what is it called [ __ ] teachers
and [ __ ] they'll give you less so you're
like oh [ __ ] I thought you got two
thousand they'll scale it right let's
just have a party at the roller rink for
a [ __ ] Key Club Key Club is dude
because
now Key Club also takes gum from under
the desk what about a rotary club all
those clubs I don't know anything about
those shits but you hear about them all
the time
leaked emails that recently came out
that show Mexico's military sold
grenades to the cartels
um this probably isn't new or surprising
to some of you guys yeah because they
got the [ __ ] Mexican Navy Seals are
working for the cartels really did you
guys see that one clip when like I think
uh they bailed out El Chapo's brother
so as they bail them out
um they sent like the military after
them and then the people that came
to protect El Chapo's brother were more
tactical and had higher Firepower than
the military themselves damn like and
all those fools just like oh [ __ ] let's
get the [ __ ] out of here let's Retreat
it's [ __ ] crazy you know it's kind of
a funny idea I like I like the idea of
um showing up to a thing with like you
just [ __ ] together this crazy
looking device but people think it's an
insane weapon but it's really just a
shitload of old computer parts and
you're just walking around and they're
like that guy's got better technology
than the military
you're just hovering over a button the
whole time let him out
[Laughter]
these guys are fighting with weapons
unseen
so Mexico's military sold hand grenades
and tactical equipments to drug cartels
according to a series of official
documents leaked by a hacker group this
looks like a video game but this is like
an image damn oh no way dude that's Call
of Duty bro I was playing that earlier I
know that see dude don't get mad at me
guys it's Mexico that's what Mexico
looks like a video game I do feel for
Mexico's [ __ ] the issue though that's
rough man how do you fight that imagine
you live in a country where they're like
Tim Kennedy and their Jocko is on the
other side I know yeah that's true
that's true yeah it's like all your
superheroes are [ __ ] villains yeah
your war heroes are on the other side
because they just get paid way better
and their families are like well often
taken care of and it's kind of funny
that like America and all our politics
are always like Mexico take care of your
[ __ ] but it's like how the [ __ ] yeah
like what can easier said than done
right they're Joe Rogan is a villain
the podcast that's on the drugs Jose
roganes
so on May 31st 2019 a military member
offered 70 hand grenades to an operator
of a criminal organization at 26 000
pesos each which is roughly thirteen
hundred dollars is that is that how much
a hand grenade is 1300 bucks for one
yeah or just one one damn that's crazy
sounds like a good deal sounds like good
value that sounds expensive as [ __ ] to
me do you have you ever owned a grenade
before a live one no don't you guys have
grenades here no dude
that's a bit it's a joke absolutely
gonna say no come on man because it look
like freaking David correction here
there's like grenades and tanks and
bullets and stuff there's live
ammunition all in Joe's office with the
safe and stuff that you guys said it's
just ingredients to makeup oh sorry
grenade package
[Laughter]
of bangdaily.com
[Laughter]
service it's a subscription service for
hand grenades it's like Dollar Shave
Club but it's [ __ ] grenades every day
you got seven a week
if you subscribe you get a package in
the mail daily wow dude yeah of grenades
people are like damn everything's been
blown up in this city this is uh there
is such thing as bad they don't work so
uh the documents were leaked after a
security breach at Mexico's defense
Ministry and published by a group called
The guacamaya the leak is one of the
Mexico it was one of Mexico's biggest
and is composed of more than 4 million
confidential documents mostly emails
from inside the Mexican Government why
would it be like have a paper trail why
wouldn't it fall off the back of the
truck you know what I mean you do you
think in like Mexico with the way they
do stuff it's just there's no way to
fight it so they're just like [ __ ] it we
don't give a [ __ ] put that on record
might as well keep the records anyways
they talk like [ __ ]
their Chicanos here should I take
accurate records of this illegal
transaction
this will never leak
will never leak it just yeah it seems
like they're helpless bro that's rough
man because a way around it would be I
know here like uh Surplus military gear
um what they'll do or outdated stuff
they'll end up selling it to the police
department
oh these are in need of stuff too
there's an old ass tank or like you know
like Novelle that's when we see tanks
and [ __ ] right flat jackets yeah these
painted blue so that's like their way of
like like reusing it um so it just
doesn't go to waste you know and then so
it could be maybe for them there is a a
broker that sells to a little war dog
yeah yeah exactly to like other police
so maybe they but this one is basically
similar but obviously it's not just
selling to other police right like this
is literally um and then the shell
company it could be cartel based it says
one of the military members selling
weapons to criminal organizations is
identified on the documents as Antigua
which means old it's military sling for
a high ranking member the message
exchange between the soldier and the
buyer came out of military base one in
Mexico City the Mexican military also
offer tactical equipment unspecified but
that can include bulletproof vests or
night vision binoculars yeah information
about rival gang members and the
whereabouts of government officials for
the right price so imagine this military
high-ranking official being like just
the fact that's even on the [ __ ] menu
of purchase like information about rival
gang members the location of [ __ ] you
know military officials just in case you
get off somebody or like you know so the
bribing is like
both ways too right it sounds like like
oh you also tell me where the other drug
kingpin lives for soccer grenades or
whatever that's crazy because like we do
obviously it sounds like if I'm like the
Mexican official yeah uh and you're like
a gang member yeah you're like bribing
me you're like uh I'm like hey give me
uh 10 000 whatever and I'll tell you
where your rival gang Nick is uh staying
at we have information and [ __ ] like
that on his gang so that's how they're
yeah because we do the same [ __ ] here
it's just there it looks like it's just
way more out of control but like here we
do that [ __ ] yeah cops will do that [ __ ]
they work together with you know with
criminals just to get the least amount
of you know they'll try to lower the
denominator a little bit so when you're
working with cops to out other criminals
Ryan oh wow what do you do
no I'm I'm uh I'm not working with cops
I'm working with criminals to out other
cops
Undercovers the real hero of our city
[Music]
foreign